Tag für Tag gehen die Kämpfe in der
Ukraine weiter stündlich gibt es weitere
Opfer
wie kann dieser Krieg beendet werden wie
kann ein Frieden dauerhaft gesichert
werden jetzt sei die Zeit diese Fragen
zu beantworten fordert der ehemalige
hochrangige Diplomat Wolfgang eschinger
das ist die klassische Aufgabe des
Auswärtigen Amts für die Bundesregierung
solche möglichen Verhandlungen vor zu
denken und das ist nicht unsere deutsche
Aufgabe allein das müssen wir mit den
beiden mit den Polen mit den anderen
Nachbarn und mit der Ukraine durch
kakeln und das ist mühselig er weiß
wovon er spricht Ischinger hat 1995 als
Unterhändler mit dafür gesorgt dass es
zum Friedensabkommen von dating kam
dieses beendete nach dreieinhalb Jahren
den Krieg in Bosnien und Herzegowina ich
bin gebranntes Kind meine britische
Kollegin mein französischer Kollege und
ich wir kamen mit sehr guten Intentionen
nach Daten um diese friedensverhandlung
zu führen aber ohne ein einziges Stück
Papier mein amerikanischer Kollege der
berühmte Richard ungefähr 1000 Seiten
vorbereitet der Option Papiere und ohne
diese umfassenden Vorbereitung hätten
wir das Ergebnis nämlich den
Friedensvertrag von denen nie
hingekriegt doch das Auswärtige Amt
hüllt sich in die Ministerin Schreck
davor zurück eine konkrete Antwort auf
die Frage nach solchen Vorbereitungen zu
geben verweist auf silenskis
Friedensplan und die UN die Mehrheit der
Staaten hat in der Generalversammlung
der Vereinten Nationen vor einigen
Wochen in New York deutlich gemacht was
die Schritte zum Frieden sind sie sind
im Kern auch verankert in der Kater der
Vereinten Nationen und das
allerwichtigste ist dass die
Kampfhandlungen eingestellt werden auf
andere Ebene zum Beispiel im Bundestag
werden die entsprechenden Szenarien
längst durchgespielt
was könnten Sicherheitsgarantien sein
wie muss man die Ukraine ausstatten ist
ein NATO-Beitritt das richtige das sind
alles Überlegungen die bereits jetzt
natürlich einen offiziell aber
inoffiziell diskutiert und überlegt
werden natürlich bereiten wir alles vor
aber dazu gehört eben auch die
Erkenntnis im Kreml dass dieser Krieg
für sie nicht zu gewinnen ist und das am
Ende eine politische Lösung die
nachhaltigere ist die FDP hält solche
Gedankenspiele für gefährlich solange
die Kämpfe weitergehen würden Gespräche
über Friedensverhandlungen die Ukraine
Schwächen schon wieder mal ist die Ampel
nicht einer Meinung das sendet Signale
nach Moskau dass wir hier im Westen
Dinge diskutieren die für Moskau nicht
in Frage kommen damit Schwächen wir die
Position der Ukraine und die Ukraine
wird nur irgendwann Gespräche führen
können mit Russland aus der Stärke
heraus und dazu gehört die militärische
Stärke der Faktor sind es wieder mal die
Amerikaner die die Initiative ergreifen
amerikanische Unterhändler sein längst
in Kiew gewesen heißt es
US-Außenminister blinken deutet ganz
vorsichtig ein Szenario für
Friedensverhandlungen an
ich glaube es wird in der Ukraine
Territorium geben für das sie auf dem
Boden kämpfen und es wird Territorium
geben bei dem sie entscheiden es auf
anderem Wege zurückzubekommen
gemeint ist damit wohl ein Verzicht auf
die Krim klar ist auf eine
Friedensinitiative Chinas kann die Welt
nicht setzen zu deutlich hat sich
Präsident Hieber seinen Besuch in Moskau
auf die Seite Putins gestellt alternativ
müsste man andere westliche Staaten
einbinden fordert nicht nur die
Opposition
da nehme ich in Deutschland derzeit als
zu passiv war insofern wäre es richtig
und notwendig dass die Bundesregierung
hier auch mit nach vorne geht und
gemeinsam mit unseren westlichen
Partnern sich vorbereitet irgendwann
Friedensverhandlungen zu führen es
werden krasser diplomatischer Fehler
nicht jeden Versuch zu unternehmen
Indien und natürlich insbesondere den
Nato-Partner Türkei ins Boot zu holen es
brauche viele Staaten die dann wenn die
Ukraine grünes Licht gibt einen Frieden
Stützen absichern oder garantieren viel
Arbeit für die Diplomaten nicht nur in
Deutschland aber eben auch da
[Musik]